ouais la pêche m la paix la paix mettra
au chômage
bon
on se connaît
le temps
et la réelle menace
[Applaudissements]
sont interchangeables
ou est ce qu'on a envie d'être
c'est ça la grande question
chacune vert
différents et chacun d'eux
est unique
vas-y doucement il ya des gens qui
comprennent rien là je parle pas de moi
quand je dis ça
qui êtes-vous
je suis capitaine carter
scheider
je suis le gardien
j'observe tout ce qui transpire de la
réalité
pas
droit d'intervenir
il va falloir que le freestyle
bush est fermé un ravageur ne vole
jamais en solo
j'ai dit ne vole jamais en solo
c'est quoi ça un jour bénigne
j'étais pas hyper rassurer
en voyage dans l'inconnu pour répondre à
l'ultime question
[Musique]
et si